he was amazing he always made people
laugh alexandra ramirez is cameron's
wife she says she's devastated and still
in shock after losing her husband they
were ready to celebrate their four-year
wedding anniversary what was supposed to
be a fun saturday night quickly made a
turn we were just on our way home and
right
our exit was right there and then the
cars started shutting down they pulled
off on the side of the freeway and then
he told me i was going to go get home
about
five to eight minutes later there was
fire trucks and
police cars and ambulance today
alexandra and cameron's friends want to
remember him with what he loved comedy
it's just one of those guys that would
leave an indelible
impression on you he's brightened every
single
person that he encountered life
he had this really really remarkable
energy about him cameron's dad artha
ramirez says cameron was a great son
father and husband but this just goes to
show you that this can happen to anybody
at any given time
every day you wake up you thank god
you're you're here i love them so much
and it's going to be really hard
to raise our three-year-old and
a fourteen-year-old but i'm gonna i'm
gonna survive
back out live friends and family plan on
honoring cameron here tonight at nine
they encourage the community to come to
artifice even if you didn't know cameron
and a gofundme page will be posted on
our website sally jaramillo live local
now